[Música]
el poder de la cartera mucho se ha
hablado de cómo las mujeres gastamos el
dinero o lo invertimos y a veces somos
objetos de algunas bromas pero déjenme
decirles que el tema de cómo compramos
las mujeres está lejos de ser una broma
nosotros las mujeres estamos tomando el
80% de las decisiones de compra a nivel
mundial qué significa esto nosotras
decidimos no sólo sobre la ropa
alimentos a donde vivimos ser cable ojos
de la suegra la escuela lo que va en los
niños los servicios médicos la
decoración de la casa que vamos a
comprar los viajes incluso muchos de
ustedes probablemente si se enferman
llamarán a su pareja a su mamá fue su
esposa y les preguntan a qué doctor voy
qué medicinas me tomo incluso pensaría
que antes ustedes se cortaban el pelo en
un barbero y desde que tienen parejas se
lo cortan donde su esposa o su mujer
va y se lo cortan
y cuántos de ustedes ha sido su pareja
quien les escoge la ropa que se van a
comprar yo sé mi esposo cuando se va de
viaje siempre toma fotos porque dice no
me arriesgo a comprarme algo que después
no te va a gustar porque lo tengo que
dejar en el closet entonces las mujeres
no sólo tomamos las decisiones sino que
también influenciamos antes éramos un
nicho de mercado hoy somos una audiencia
somos más de la mitad de la población en
el 2014 manejamos 18 trillones del gasto
mundial hoy estamos con 20 que se debe
esto pues primero lo más lógico muchos
de los hogares están liderados por
mujeres en costa rica casi un 40 por
ciento de las mujeres son las jefas de
hogar
esto significa que ellas toman todas las
decisiones en las casas pero además hay
varios factores cada vez más existen
mujeres que están retrasando la edad
para casarse muchas escogen no casarse
si tomamos en cuenta también que el 50
por ciento de los matrimonios terminan
en divorcio y que las mujeres vivimos
más que los hombres vamos a tener
siempre algún momento en nuestras vidas
donde vamos a tomar todas las decisiones
adicionalmente cada vez nos estamos
preparando mucho más en costa rica de
todos los graduados universitarios las
mujeres somos el 63% en eeuu y en
argentina somos el 60 en canadá el 55 en
londres perdón en inglaterra una mujer
que nazca este año tiene 75 por ciento
más de probabilidad en comparación con
el hombre de ir a la universidad
esto hace entonces que también nosotros
queramos disminuir la cantidad de hijos
que tenemos y sabemos que los niños son
una bendición pero las que somos mamás
sabemos que también es muy difícil
compaginar todo por lo tanto ya las
familias de seis o más hijos ya no son
la norma ahora por lo menos en costa
rica la norma es 1.9
esto hace que nosotros podamos ingresar
al mundo laboral en mayores números
aunque todavía existe la barrera del
techo de cristal si estamos participando
mucho más que antes y estamos también
teniendo nuestros propios ingresos los
cuales ayudan a reactivar la economía
que significa la mujer el dinero que
tiene lo gasta en alimentos educación y
salud mientras que el hombre en
entretenimiento y alcohol
otro factor importante es la diferencia
que existe en la expectativa de vida
como la mujer se cuida más tiende a ir
al médico más y ser más saludable las
mujeres estamos viviendo un promedio de
6 años más que el hombre todo esto nos
lleva a explicar por qué tomamos las
decisiones de compra y además un nuevo
término que se llama la economía
femenina o el lifting económico
pero además de las compras tradicionales
las mujeres estamos empezando a comprar
cosas que antes se denominaba
tradicionalmente masculinas por ejemplo
en la región el 70 por ciento de las
pymes lideradas por mujeres no tienen
acceso al crédito bancario quien se los
va a dar hagamos una cosa comprar un
carro el año pasado fui a comprarme un
carro y cometí el gran error de llevar a
mi pareja porque error porque lo
atendieron a él pero a mi carro mi
dinero pero la tienen ahí y lo llevan a
ver el motor créanme que yo nunca ha
abierto la tapa en mi carro
para mí el motor no es sexy escuchar el
ruido del motor no me gusta nadie me
parece que me aturde a mí me gusta ver
si yo me puedo montar o no con tacones
si me puedo montar y bajarme con vestido
sin que se vea nada donde pongo mi
cartera y mi café y por supuesto lo más
importante para mí no son los caballos
de fuerza lo cual me han tratado de
explicar y no entiendo y no me interesa
entender lo más importante es el color
pues así compramos nosotras entonces
quiero explicarles o darles algunos
consejos de cómo pueden hacer para
conocer a las mujeres el primero es la
división demográfica tradicional no es
un verdadero diferenciador a qué me
refiero con esto pues muy sencillo los
que hemos planeado estrategias podemos
hacer una diferenciación como la
siguiente con mi producto voy a llegarle
a mujeres estudiantes universitarias de
18 a 24 años del gran área metropolitana
correcto ahora bien eso es asumiendo que
ellas todas son iguales y compran igual
pero no es así por ejemplo un caso
hipotético yo tengo una hermana gemela
fuimos a la misma escuela misma o
colegio misma universidad
trabajamos en la misma empresa tenemos
el mismo puesto y ganamos el mismo
salario por aquí todo igual pensaríamos
que entonces compramos igual pero no es
así si yo estoy divorciada con una hija
y ella está soltera nuestras compras van
a ser totalmente diferentes lo que ella
basa en un viernes por la noche o un
sábado por la mañana es totalmente
diferente a lo que yo voy a hacer al
cine en una película de adultos yo
probablemente iré a ver alguna fábula
en fin de año ella probablemente ir a
algún lugar donde hay mucha fiesta yo
tendré que buscar hoteles donde hay
actividades para niños
cuando vamos al súper ella tendrá una
lista de compras y yo probablemente
tendré otra que puede incluir hasta
pañales entonces no es sólo el dinero
que tenemos sino el momento de la vida
en que nos encontramos el cual se define
por tenemos una pareja tenemos uno niños
otro punto importante es no pensar en
rosado ni hacer productos diferenciados
que me refiero con esto el rosado es mi
color favorito pero no quiero una
tarjeta de crédito rosada no quiero que
me impriman los contratos en rosado no
quiero un carlos rosado
simplemente eso no es lo que a mí me
motiva me gusta el mismo carro de
hombres créanme lo puedo manejar pero
nada más me gusta que me lo vendan
diferente esto ha inducido arbor y hay
empresas que han tenido que pagar el
precio de este por ejemplo del bel se
dio cuenta que las mujeres también
podemos usar computadoras y decidió
hacer una marca especial para ellas le
puso de la era especial para mujeres por
lo tanto era rosada celeste y verde y
que hacía para nosotras pues dos cosas
tremendamente sencillas podemos bajar
recetas más fácil que los hombres y
podríamos contar calorías
esto duró 48 horas en el mercado de ahí
la mala resolución de este pantallazo
que encontré porque de él ha hecho
grandes esfuerzos por volver en la
historia de que de la existió y ahora
qué sucede con las mujeres tendremos que
comprar las mismas computadoras
complicadísimas de los hombres y
aprender a usar esto
otro punto importante servicio si
ustedes le venden a un hombre hacen una
venta si ustedes le venden a una mujer
consiguen una clienta porque porque las
mujeres hablamos un ejemplo un hombre se
toca otro hombre y a veces puede ser que
esta conversación sé de qué linda está
tu corbata gracias
final de la conversación
como sería si somos dos mujeres que un
niño está tu vestido hay muchísimas
gracias lo comprenda entienda me costó
tanto estaba en descuento la tienda está
en tal lugar hay en tantos colores en
tantas fallas además habían otras blusas
divinas pero había una que a mí no me
quedó entonces no me la compré si
quieres te la fulanita que te atiende se
llama tal y tal el más si quieres vamos
juntas y yo te acompaño cierto no cuando
nosotros nos gusta algo lo recomendamos
no me tienen que ofrecer cosas si a mí
me gusta yo lo a recomendar pero si no
me gusta o no me tratan bien esperen un
mensajito en facebook o en alguna red
social porque las mujeres hablamos y el
servicio hace la gran diferencia por eso
vemos que las mujeres vamos casi siempre
al mismo estilista porque no es que
exista una única persona en el mundo que
pueda manejar nuestro cabello es que si
fuimos donde esa persona nos trató bien
y tuvimos una tarde o una mañana la
pasamos bien seguiremos yendo
otro punto importante productos que nos
ayuden a ahorrar tiempo las mujeres
independientemente si trabajamos dentro
o fuera del hogar tenemos múltiples
ocupaciones no podemos hacer grandes
filas no vamos a llenar 300 documentos
no podemos tener reuniones de tres horas
todo lo que nos ayude a ahorrar tiempo y
hacer las cosas más sencillas va a
prevalecer sobre otras cosas por ejemplo
costa rica se ha vuelto un país donde es
cada vez más difícil transitar entonces
si yo iba en un sector y el mejor doctor
está totalmente del otro sector
probablemente yo me iré al que queda más
cerca mi casa aunque sea el número dos o
el número tres igual para las tiendas o
igual para servicios
y para finalizar busquemos si queremos
llegar al mercado femenino busquemos
valorar su esencia yo no voy a comprar
un automóvil porque haya una mujer
semidesnuda montada en la tapa y créanme
que mi esposo tampoco
vamos a comprar productos
vamos a comprar productos que valoren
nuestra esencia vean lo exitosa que ha
sido la campaña de dos si bien es cierto
todas admiramos a las muchachas de
victoria's secrets la realidad es que lo
más cercano que vamos a estar de esos
cuerpos es la televisión viéndolas
porque en la vida real no es tan fácil
pero las campañas de dos valoran nuestra
belleza que nuestra belleza va más allá
de la talla o de las curvas campañas que
valoren nuestra inteligencia nuestro
valor como mujer
nuestra capacidad nuestro coraje y
nuestra fuerza son campañas que van a
ser mucho más exitosas los invito para
que ustedes en sus empresas entiendan el
valor que tenemos las mujeres que nos
sepan llegar como mercado y que
aprendamos todos hablar mujer muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]